[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like British if you ain't thick
please don't get involved
now Brandon
what is popping kid it is a gloomy rainy
Monday morning November 7th we have
quite the fight coming up we have the
UFC return to Madison Square Garden UFC
2 81 is going down this mother Trucking
Saturday my boy Izzy versus Alex Pierre
is your main event coming event Carla
sparza waylay you got uh big boy fight
Dustin Poirier and Michael Chandler at
lightweight you got the fan favorite
Frankie Edgar in his send-off fight not
an easy fight and you got Dan hooker and
uh fighting as well I'm not that
lightweight fighting that prelims Brad
Riddell versus Ronaldo McConnell is a
great one Dominic Grace Dominic Graves
and Dan hooker kind of in the same boat
they both need to get a win pretty bad
pretty bad we'll get in the card though
but I'm looking forward to this one
unfortunately won't be able to do a
fight campaign for this one because I
would be in Houston this Thursday Friday
Saturday Houston Improv coming to you
live with the thick boy Squad with the
oh he thick tour that's Houston this
Thursday Friday Saturday there's an
appearance Saturday at the specs in
Houston
let me check the exact address everyone
keeps asking for the address that's from
noon to two on Saturday and that is at
specs in downtown Houston when I say
downtown I don't know Houston so I'm
just gonna say downtown right now that
is the specs at
two was it 241
I think you're right on Smith Street
yeah it's 241 Smith Street baby holler
that's from noon to two come try that
award-winning sweet thick nectar two
four one zero Smith Street Houston Texas
baby
Houston Texas I'll be there uh with this
crew come try some of that award-winning
whiskey come get you some cases uh some
bottles we'll be doing giveaways we have
some cool stuff there for you guys so
that's Saturday in downtown Houston
specs
um yep and two shows that night two
shows Friday one shows Thursday Houston
come get some next week I'm in Milwaukee
those shows are only Friday Saturday
Friday's Milwaukee hometown of Jeffrey
Dahmer and then first week of December
Providence Rhode Island December 1st
through the 3rd that all those shows are
almost sold out and watching DC DC
Improv is December 15th through the 17th
one of my favorite venues in all the
land good to see you guys though shout
out to San Antonio had a great time San
Antonio shout out to 2m barbecue Hotel
Emma all of it man at a grand old time
let's get right into the fights though
man
um you know UFC 281 UFC 281 is here at
Mass Square Garden there's been some
Infamous Fights Mexican garden that's
where
um our boy TJ Dillashaw knocked out Cody
garbrandt I think that's where Rose
knocked out Joanna Jung check
um there's been some big fights there
some really big fights so
um it's a special thing when the UFC's
in uh New York and this card has special
written all freaking over it
um there's a lot going on on this card
definitely worth your money you know
it's rare I tell you guys it's worth
your 80 bucks but this one is definitely
worth it the last one was too but this
one is fantastic I like the prelims my
boy
um Philly's Finest Andre petrovski find
Willington Truman uh you know I'm taking
Andre a freaking day shout out to Andre
Petroski yacht Molly the meatball
fighting on there as well as well they
gave her a tough matchup they didn't do
any favors with uh Aaron blanchefield
she she's quite the underdog
I know she's cool with Jake she's she's
mates with Drake I don't think the UFC
cares they did not give her a favorable
matchup her and uh her and Patty you
know they're getting tougher fights
which is how it goes
um but there's a there's a underlying
theme on this card you know there's
there's some fan favorites Dominic Reyes
everyone loves Dan hooker Frankie Edgar
and they have two uh you know Dustin
poorey
all those names I just mentioned really
need to win
really need to win Dominic Reyes change
camps he's over it with Global Tech
share now
um obviously I'm sure you did camp with
Dr Pierre and Glover so that should help
him Ryan span's not the easiest fight
for the guy who's taking some time off
doesn't want to fight in hot second
burst on the scene like a goddamn
Banshee obviously you have that uh
controversial fight with Jon Jones and
then now he's falling on tough times so
it's going to get dice for me we're
gonna lose this one I think I'd be four
in a roaching if he lost three or two in
a right there pretty sure it's three in
a row Atomic rays
you got three in a row you lost Jon
Jones right controversial they probably
don't hold that against him lost to yawn
all right guys champ and they lost a
year he got was The Champ so he's he's
losing to the best of the best
um but yeah he's gonna have to he's
fought for the title twice so it's like
this is important one man God he came
out like a goddamn Banshee I know he's
smart too because you know he's suffered
two pretty bad Knockouts the KO spinning
back elbow from Yuri and the TKO from uh
yawn so he's taking time off just to let
his brain heal smart thing smart thing
dude but that ring rust is real so Ryan
spans no punk they're not doing domic
Reyes or Dan hooker any favors with the
matchups they're giving these guys so
uh listen I'm siding with my boy uh dom
dom there I think he gets it done he's
worked hard but yeah they're not doing
any favors nor should they you know he's
fighting Jon Jones Yuri and
um John so it's not like you can get
just some random dude Ryan spins no punk
um then for Dan hooker same thing right
he's messing around 145 and then uh 155
is probably pretty natural for him he's
won one out of his last five
um he's lost his last two
so you know the dude doesn't want to
fight in a hot second and um again
they're not doing any favors the guy's
fighting is no punk but you're also Dan
hooker so what are you gonna do these
guys are in tough positions man really
tough positions where they're that you
gotta win
you gotta freaking win so you know the
Arnold Allen thing was kind of uh
it was a tough one that's a tough one uh
Arnold Allen I told you as my Dark Horse
with that division especially at
featherweight so he decides to go down
to featherweight and like here's Arnold
Allen hooker he's also I think one of
the reasons a lot of us cheer for him
too is he's such a good dad and family
man remember with uh New Zealand and
finding out Australia remember they
basically had to do an underground Fight
Club out there that's how strict it was
and he was getting stuck and they're
holding them in you know quarantine and
[ __ ] so the guy you can't help but root
for him man so God I'm really rooting
for uh all three of the guys real well
listen you got Dominic Rays we need him
to win Dan hooker you need to win and
Frankie Edgar it's his last fight who
the hell this isn't anything against
Chris Gutierrez who the hell is rooting
for Chris Gutierrez against Frankie
Edgar if you're a goddamn American who
the hell is going to root against Frank
Yeager his send-off fight Mass Square
Garden how dare you I know Frank Yeager
won Dominic Cruz but
I like this for him unless there's also
gonna be Donna Cruz they're not fighting
that's kind of fun but I'm down for this
for Frankie Edgar
definitely down he's always tough one to
beat at least Chris isn't like a crazy
knockout artist the last thing anybody
wants to see is Frank get knocked out so
the one where I'm not gonna pick because
they're two of my buddies uh is that
that's important Michael Chandler I'll
talk about the fight but you're that's
the only fight you're not getting a pick
on out of me
um this fight has so many heavy
consequences when it comes to
lightweight division because the guy who
loses you jump way back in the queue and
there's some killers in the queue and
it's changing at the time so you know
you look at guys who ran the division
forever you look at Tony uh Ferguson you
had khabib there forever Connor's doing
his damn thing everybody's getting older
Charles Oliveira just lost he's been UFC
for literally ever since he was 21.
um so you got Justin gaichi there uh
Darius isn't exactly a young buck
hoffield dos anchos like it's a bit of
an older Vibe but you got these new
Savages coming in and kind of gonna run
things so for ju for uh Dustin Porey and
Michael Chandler it's like whoever loses
this is gonna fall back in the queue and
then there's guys like dare you should
deserve a title shot there's physive
deserves it you know uh to be right up
there yeah gamrat just waiting the the
freaking line there so you got all these
Savages just waiting waiting Armin is a
freaking nightmare Jalen Turner
nightmare so it's like whoever loses
this one you probably gonna be a very
tough path to get the title shot there's
so many good guys waiting so you know
for Dustin who he said he would only
take a fight there give him out of bed
give him excited I thought it was gonna
be the Nate fight but it ended up
happening my channel is a good one and
they have a bit of bad blood bad history
there then was fight at the UFC if you
remember they don't like each other
everyone you know Dustin thinks
Chandler's fake and they used to be
training Partners ATT so there's a good
uh back story there it's a fantastic
fight
um you know you just gotta wonder who is
just gonna be up here slower who's going
to make one mistake and as far as
knockout power goes I'd give the advance
of Michael challenge so that worries me
with poorier going in this fight but
probably damn near impossible to finish
so
um it's giving me a great fight that has
five Night written all over unless
Chandler was to land one of those big
bombs which is notoriously known for but
um you know for Chandler he's kind of
the OC's Golden Boy you know he was
hoping for a gigantic fight there's a
lot of talk you know pairing him up with
Connor there's all sorts of chatter
online about what his next fight was
going to be and he had a big one he got
a big fish on the line with Dustin pore
Man Legends so looking forward to that
fight
and co-main event I know you got Carla
Esparza who's just been on this
Savage streak to get to you know
Championship status
um I think three of those six wins or
three of those seven wins how much you
want to Roach in six or seven but a lot
of those split decisions right so she's
on one two three four five six so before
that lost to Tatiana Suarez who I
thought was gonna be champ who knows
what's going on with her neck
um but she had a split decision or a
majority decision a lot of decisions
there dude she's out of holy [ __ ] out of
those six fights they're all decisions
except for one
um and then also uh out of those six
wins out of those decisions half those
wins are split so it could go either way
so she had to win over rose right to to
win the belt
um should be Marina Rodriguez that's a
good win split again Michelle Waterson
split
I just I I just don't see her finishing
wayley I just don't I don't see her
finish or can she be in a decision I'm
sure I just what were the odds I assume
Whaley's a heavy favorite chin let's see
on DraftKings minus 350 minus 350. that
makes sense poor is a minus 280 damn is
he minus 180 wow wow wow Frank Yeager's
a dog
hooker's favorite thank God
that Brad rodel Renato messino fights
can be fantastic Petroski are boys minus
200. all right Dom gray is mice to 25.
that's surprising that one will laugh
over Ryan span to look at a girl Molly
meatball plus 320. yeah that's big
that's a tough one
Carolina versus Silvana Gomez Juarez
even uh juarez's First Team all batty
Montel Jordan just kidding Montel
Jackson minus 205. interesting man yeah
interesting yeah I just listen good for
uh Carlos sparzik in the the title and
stuff like that and go on the six fight
win streak I think the the bus stops
that in China with waylay you know all
right listen waley's only really lost
two rows she beats everybody not named
Rose if your name's not Rose you're
probably gonna get beat up Rose is just
her Achilles heel and I think listen for
for Rose the best part to get back to
the title she needs welee to win and
then she'll become champ and then she'll
fight not wayleigh and then she'll have
to fight way late you know so Carlos
sparza in that split you know it's tough
dude the whims to boot straw it's fun
but if you're a rose fan this is best
case scenario because wayle will beat
because
waylay matches up bad with Carla right
it's a tough fight for Carla Carla
matches up good with rose rose matches
up good with way late that's how it goes
man anyone can be Champs it just depends
how their timing is so if you're a rose
fan which I am I've known that girl
forever
um we want wayley to win this fight and
then call Out rose and then she's gonna
fight Rose I'm sure she wants that fight
and Roses her Achilles heel
let's take a little break y'all I'm just
chatting your ear off as you're driving
into work Houston I will see this
Thursday Friday Saturday Houston Improv
come meet your boy and try that new
award-winning tiger thick sweet nectar
at specs 12 to 2 on Saturday during the
day the whole thick boy crew will be
there come say what's up come try the
whiskey come ask whatever questions you
want I'll be doing a q a all sorts of
fun stuff that that specs downtown
Houston I'll post the exact address on
my social media today Houston this
Thursday Friday Saturday next week is
Milwaukee Friday Saturday only Milwaukee
improv Providence Rhode Island December
1st through the 3rd those shows almost
sold out so if we sell out soon I'll add
some shows but get your tickets
Providence Rhode Island I've never been
there looking forward to it then I end
the year the Ohi thick tour in
Washington DC DC Improv December 15th
through the 17th of December get your
tickets at thickboy.com
this episode of the shop show is brought
to you by my friends at DraftKings and
guess what UFC 281 is live from New York
this freaking Saturday get closer to the
octagon with DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting partner the UFC
right now new customers can bet five
dollars on UFC 281 and get 200 in free
bets if your fighter wins check this out
right now everyone can earn up to 100
boost with draftking stepped up parlays
go to DraftKings Sportsbook app plays a
parlay today with three or more picks
and combine multiple bets like which
fighter will win total rounds and so
much more little parlay you could take
the favorites you could take waylay you
could take Izzy you could take Dustin
Poirier the three of them are favorites
but you know I can make much money
better on the face by themselves so the
way to boost your odds put all three of
them together and then do your thing all
right with payouts bigger than ever
draftking Sportsbook is where I go to
bed on UFC it's the only place I go
because they send my money when I need
it those have the best odds download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app right now use
promo code shop show schab show throw
down five dollars on the UFC 281 to get
200 in free bets if your fighter wins
that's code shop show this Saturday at
DraftKings Sportsbook the official
Sports button part of the UFC minimum
age eligible restrictions by C show
notes for details DraftKings
another little break to keep the house
lights on and pay the thick boy staff
this holiday season I'll be giving
thanks to our friends over at manscaped
everyone loves turkey and stuffing but
you'll be looking like a dessert with
the manscapes help performance package
4.0 the leaders in below the way
screwing have the blessed you with the
ultimate Thanksgiving dinner topic tell
your in-laws about your new Cutting Edge
ball trimmer and give gift yourself or
the man in your life the ultimate men's
hygiene bundle trim your pumpkins by
going to manscape.com use the code
shop20 schab20 for free shipping with 20
off the best manscaping products on the
planet what else are you gonna use I
would love to hear it dude think your
holiday spread is good it's time to give
thanks to manscape Performance package
4.0 or as I like to call it the perfect
package for yo package inside you find
the lawnmower 4.0 the weed whacker ears
nose hair trimmer crop preserver ball
deodorant crop reviver toner performance
boxes and a travel bag to hold all your
goodies all right it's fantastic we got
you covered man all right gifted
manscaped is the ultimate hack to become
the family favorite we got you guys
covered quit nicking your balls they
bleed like crazy all right don't do that
anymore it's 2022. how many times have I
told you guys about manscapes I swear by
him it's the only thing that touched his
face and this weiner all right get twins
off and free shipping with Coach shop20
sh ab20 at bandscape.com this twimps off
with free shipping at manscape.com use
code shop20 be thankful this holiday
season for the best gift of all from
manscaped your balls will thank you now
let's get back to the program
the main event Yeah Izzy arasania Alex
Pierre
um I know everybody's on Pierre's giant
Brazilian nut sack right now and I get
it big scary guy knocking dudes out he
knocked out Sean Strickland he had that
jumping uh knee me and Eric Griffin
broke it down and Fight Night flashback
last week you haven't seen it go watch
it because Eric didn't know either of
these two
um but if you look at this is I'm not
sold on period yet you know I know why
the UFC fast tracked him and basically
they're doing it it's a byproduct of the
way Izzy's been winning they want to get
they want Stoke of fire under Izzy
because remember when Izzy first burst
on the scene he was fun he was finishing
guys it's not that he's not fun now but
in order to get the best out of Izzy you
got to come forward and you gotta take
chances and I think now that Izzy's this
mythical legend in the middleweight
division guys are very tentative and so
you're getting kind of a boring fight
because Izzy's like I'm not putting my
title on the line if you're dumb ass is
just gonna sit there leave the yo Romero
fight he's like why wouldn't I I'm
already the jam dude why am I gonna risk
all this come get it if you want to get
him come get it a lot of these guys
aren't willing to risk that because they
know they can get started so
UFC Fast Track Pier which I don't really
have an issue with I think it's
short-sighted I'll get to that but so
they fast tracked here and and gave them
the perfect matchup to get to Izzy
because if they give them anybody else
outside the top seven besideshawn
Strickland they're gonna wrestle the
[ __ ] out of them and they can't afford
that loss because then Pierre definitely
another time shot he jumps back in the
queue they don't have the Nair between
him and Izzy and obviously the narrative
everybody knows this by now is Pierre
beat him twice in kickboxing my issue
with that if you're going to predicate
this fight in your decision to bet on
Pierre over Izzy off those two
kickboxing matches eight was kickboxing
not MMA smaller gloves B
it was a long time ago in five years
it's forever ago they've both gotten
better but one has gotten better in
mixed martial arts and one has been
fighting the best of the best at the
highest possible level in being
successful for 25 minutes and his name
is not Alex Pierre Pierre has never
fought for 25 minutes in the UFC Izzy
that's all he knows he knows how to win
you might say oh well it's boring or it
wasn't exciting doesn't matter the guy
knows how to win at that level oxpeare
does it you tell me Oxford is going to
figure that out for the first time ever
in Mass Square Garden in the main event
against Izzy I beg to differ I don't
think you will now can he
catches it yeah if this is a video game
or going through you know their their
attributes and their talent and there's
there's a you know those weird graph
charts and stuff Pierre has more uh
knockout power than Izzy I'll give you
that but as far as technique goes as far
as MMA goes experience speed
um you know kind of uh the Mastery of
mixed martial arts especially when it
comes to kickboxing in the UFC
check check it all goes to Izzy Izzy
checks way more boxes as a mixed martial
artist than um uh Alex Pierre the other
thing is too you know
I don't think I think a lot of people go
well you tell me is he's been you know
trading this long he makes so much less
you'll know how to wrestle if you have
to you have to wrestle he would uh take
Alex down I don't think that's going to
be a big factor in this fight I know
people think uh Izzy might shoot
I think Izzy one of the reasons that
makes him special is he can figure guys
out on the Fly And even though he you
know it might not be the most exciting
thing he can figure him out figure out a
way to win I think him especially not
having a wrestling background no one
actually Bears knees and guys that shoot
in it's a huge risk and that's not
really his bread and butter I don't see
is he fighting I or I'm sorry is he
wrestling or grappling I also don't see
Izzy
um
submitting to that the narrative that he
needs to wrestle to beat him I think is
he knows he's more Technical and has a
speed advantage and has the experience
to Advantage the main event level
fighting for 25 minutes so I think you
could see Izzy win uh decision like a
four to one decision and last Oxford and
he would love this and but it's not
going to happen
um alexapira
you know the way you beat a guy who's
more technical than you is you make it a
brawl Knox Pierre is praying to the
Brazilian gods that Izzy has a moment
where he goes I can knock this guy out
I'm just gonna let it fly because then
that favors Alex Pierre and that's
really Alex Pierre's only way to win not
your ideas it's his only way to win is
if Izzy goes [ __ ] all the trading [ __ ]
what my coaches say
kind of what John Strickland did when
Sean Strickland was on future what were
you thinking he's like the game plan was
staying with him a little bit and then
shooting and I just figured man I'm kind
of winning this war you might for a
little bit but the guy hit so goddamn
hard you're playing such a risky game
man and he suffered a major loss due to
that he's not Izzy Izzy's one of the
thing that makes Izzy special same thing
that makes Jon Jones specials the the
most cerebral fighters in the game
they're the smartest guys we have to
offer so I think for Izzy
and if you go back and watch the fight
where you got knocked out Izzy again the
smarter fighter uh more technical if it
was UFC they would have stopped that
fight they would have stepped in stop
the fight there's a point where you know
he he did uh concuss him and was doing
work against them but then he got into
the exchange of power shots and oxpiera
loves you know he's your huckleberry he
loves to play that power game and as he
decided to play that power game if you
watch an interview with his coach he
goes I know is you thinking the whole
freaking fight we told him don't get
into that war with him dude you're
winning the fight do not get in that
exchange with Ox beer it's a bad idea is
he had a uh you know an air and a mental
judgment there and ended up getting
knocked out and now all you guys are
buying the narrative that is he's just
gonna get knocked out again that's
[ __ ] stupid
that's assuming Izzy from whatever the
fight was five six years ago is the same
fighter he's definitely not is he's a
very cerebral smart fighter has too much
to risk to go out there and play Texas
shoot him uh with a freaking guy like
Jack's Pier he's gonna sit on the
outside pick him apart Alex and get
frustrated come in the only way you get
a finish is if Alex were to land
something unconventional on Izzy but
really the only way you're getting an
exciting finish of this fight the Vox
player goes all right I'm getting
destroyed on the outside I need to start
taking some risks like a Whitaker like
Apollo Costa you come in and get knocked
out because the vax beer does get
frustrated at one point again he's never
been this level magnitude of a fight and
if he's embarrassed and his ego gets to
him and his coaches we would go out on
our Shield you're sitting back there
getting picked apart we're down for
three rounds now experience [ __ ] it
let's do it Russia's in because he's
gonna start you I and so I if I had to
guess on this I think that's what
happened in the fight is he starches
them in the fourth or fifth round due to
Alex Pierre and his Corner going we're
gonna go on our Shield you're sitting
back you can pick the part you're not
fast enough the technique's not there to
master with him Toe to Toe we gotta
start taking some chances we take chance
chance Izzy the reason why he's gonna be
the best middleweight of all time is
because once you take chances he takes
advantage of that your momentum's coming
forward he's Gonna Knock You Out I
predict is Evia knockout late in the
rounds fourth or fifth round and that's
because that Alex is down on the cards
and his Corner tells him go out on your
shield and then he gets finished
and then as he goes on now the alternate
to that
that a lot of you betters out there
wanna
fancy zaxbyer is just going to do the
same thing he did when they fought in
kickbox and knock him out let's talk
about it let's say
if you're an easy fan excuse me don't be
mad at my uh
my uh Norman cup there
that's right
nor McDonald cup
let's talk about why it's so
short-sighted for the UFC to press Alex
appear up in this championship fight
well let's say oxpeare does what some of
you better think and Alex Pierre knocks
is he out
immediate rematches he's held the the
the belt too long not to give a guy if
his caliber immediate rematch he's also
now that Nate Diaz is gone Connor's on
yachts and he's out of the testing
protocol Alex is I'm sorry Izzy's also
your biggest star he's your biggest
pay-per-view draw internationally and
locally he's big here he's big
everywhere he connects as far as with
the younger crowd the older crowd
everyone appreciates Izzy so you know
take a guy next period doesn't speak
great English but looks like a monster I
don't know how many followers he has on
Instagram not that matters but UFC does
put uh emphasis on that so you can take
a guy in Knox Pierre you're gonna Rush
him this time shot he knocks out his you
get immediate rematch let's say for
whatever reason this weird mixed martial
arts world that we live in he ends up
knocking Izzy out twice so he has 500
000 followers
so say he ends up knocking out Izzy
twice
well then what are you gonna do
what do you do with the guy
go to the top 10 the middleweight
division chin so let's say he just has
his number and Izzy just can't figure
out so a you're ruining your biggest
pay-per-view star uh hands down so then
uh you know Robert Whitaker or Robert
Whittaker's background is he was going
to be on the Australian national team
for wrestling so he can wrestle so if
anyone can rest at a high level I
experience [ __ ] and we know this from
earlier in his fights and he also gets
hit from time to time even at the High
Caliber uh striking level that he's at
again he's not the most technical guy
but for the UFC standards he's very high
level he's high level anyway he's a K1
Champion Glory Champion so you know to
have that pedigree he's gonna be a high
level Striker but he does take chances
he does get hit if you go back and watch
UFC fights
so let's say beats Izzy twice he's the
champ he's the face of middleweight
division is he has to go back to jump go
down the queue so you look at any of the
matchups I would love to hear which
matchup he's favored in let's go through
his options Robert Whitaker can wrestle
can also strike has knockout power
terrible matchup for Experia the best
matchup possible for Alex Pierre is Izzy
because he will only stand with him and
that's sane a lot Jay Cannon there big
can wrestle beats him marmotori pressure
wrestles beats him Derek Brunson
wrestles good cardio beats him
Paulo Costa may be because wrestling's
not great would be a fun matchup
Jack Hermanson from Grandpa's ass off
Darren till be a good fight I would
imagine if Darren till wins wins when's
Till's fight December 10th right I don't
know I'll look he had that eye Angie
better not [ __ ] pull out but
um
Darren Till's a good matchup for Alex
Pierre yeah you're right yeah that's a
really good fight for dinner Darren till
uh Alex Pierre is a fantastic fight but
again go you go through those top seven
or eight guys all I'll experience and
Underdog in every single one of those
fights it's very short-sighted very
short-sighted but I think UFC's banking
on uh is he getting the win here they're
banking on this Stoke in the fire to get
him out of his as they say safe uh kind
of mode he's in right now which I
disagree with I think it's more has to
do with the guys that he's fighting so
um I just think it's short-sighted I
know it's new blood and this is a fun
narrative talk about on Alex beat him
previously and blah blah blah but I just
I don't see it I would rather Alex walk
through some fire to get to uh Izzy
that's really not how this should work
but here we are but I think Izzy gets it
done what do you got Jen alrighty
the reason why I went straight into the
fights and didn't freaking play grab ass
with you guys today is I have three
shows today I got this shop show I have
find the kid and then I have a food
truck without Jermaine Sterling
and then tomorrow we have my perry food
truck next week you have Paige yep oh
yeah we're doing the damn thing
I don't want you to you want to cover
any of the fights this weekend but
the one that stands out to me the most
is Neil magni yeah yeah 100 Neil Magnus
that the record for most wins at
welterweight and then he called out
um Gilbert Burns which I think is a
great fight did it did Burns respond
I'll see I think he did
and what did he get uh uh Rodriguez with
a darstroke could begin with guilty
star Stars hell yeah
he was the most underrated guy one of
the most underrated guys in the UFC
let's see yep congratulations he said I
have an opponent for Brazil if you don't
show up we can dance I'm 100 to make
this fight happen for now great finish
and congrats on your record that's a big
deal dude
I wonder who the opponent is for Gilbert
in Brazil and the UFC could easily
switch that opponent its skills has to
be a big name I wonder who it is
that's a fun fight though and Neil
deserves it
especially if you can keep it standing
I'll see Jiu Jitsu kneels Achilles heel
at a high high level those guys you know
he tons of problems with him he said
mazured all verbally agreed before
Jesus Christ that's a huge that's a big
fight if you're a kill you definitely
want to stick with Mozilla not Neil
magni no no disrespect to Neil magni but
I was at all that's a big old Cuban fish
on the line
um okay so during these fights as well I
guess this is the most that it's ever
happened that people Miss wait for the
fights so it was five people at first
but then one girl eventually cut her
hair and they was able to make weight
her hair was the appearance what kind of
hair did she have some dreads yeah
dreads are happy I saw some drugs oh is
it dreads yeah yep yep way too much
first 48. it's the dreadlocks gets them
every time this homeboy like crazy that
guy looks like he came straight out of a
concentration camp that guy is looking
tough
gonna die on weight wow five missed it
and then they pulled the heavyweight uh
fight off with my boy Chase Sherman
because his opponent had some irregular
heart do you hear about this right
before the fight they literally yanked
it uh right after Wayans hit something
with his heart that sucks
so really six people didn't fight but
I'm sorry
six Miss way five minutes wait five
minutes wait then one had a heart issue
oh yeah it's saying just fights that
didn't you yeah man six fights had some
issues five of those kids of weight one
cut their dreads the dreads look heavy
mm-hmm it's just like it smell like they
look stinky I don't it looks stinky on
House of dragons there's a lot of dreads
a lot of dreads like all [ __ ]
you have to put like wax in your hair
you get those dreads and not wash it
yeah so here smells like hummus that's
got to be dreads right that's dreads 100
yeah 100 of that stretched
yeah it's a micro with dreads huh [ __ ]
yeah
interesting this is not a big deal but
we'll just go watch a quick video this
is a bare knuckle bkfc over the weekend
I guess one guy got uh disqualified and
there was a bit of a brawl and the guy
the main guy from bkfc that President
yeah he got involved too so just hit it
why do you get disqualified
oh
and where's the uh oh there oh
yeah you can't have that stuff damn did
that uh president take him down yeah so
I'll just show you the he shot a double
here's a slow motion of it
oh no he just fell back he didn't take
him down then he fell down on top of him
he just wanted to stop it because
especially repair knuckle this is what
people want right this meaning like be
like yeah bare Knuckles these guys are
barbarians look at him just fighting so
that's the last thing he wants if you
have sponsors and endorsement deals last
thing you want
this episode of the shop show is brought
to you by betterhelp sometimes I wish
life came with a manual I really do I
wish came to a man like hey if you're
gonna make this decision you should need
help with this you need to do this all
right but unfortunately life doesn't
come with a user manual it just doesn't
so when it's not working free and you're
getting your way and your normal life
you feel stuck not getting any life's
challenges can make you feel unsure with
career change a new relationship
becoming a parent whatever it is there's
a lot going on in the world and thank
God for my friends that better help
better help us connected over three
million people with licensed therapists
not your friends not your family we're
talking about professional licensed
therapists it's convenient it's
accessible anywhere
100 online 100
online all right and I use better help I
sometimes I have to switch my therapist
maybe I'm just not feeling one or maybe
they're great but it's not a fit for me
it's so easy to change I've done it a
few times myself all right so uh as the
world's largest therapy service better
help has matched three million people
with professionally licensed vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking like I told
you guys you can easily switch a new
therapist anytime you want can be easier
no waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist we got
you man learn more and save 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com
Schaub that's betterhelp help.com shop
after years of fine print Contracting
and ripped off by big Wireless providers
which we've all been there if we've
learned anything it's that there's
always a cat so when I first heard that
mint mobile offers premium Wireless
starting at just 15 bucks a month and I
was like oh I see Ryan Reynolds on the
commercial commercials Ryan Reynold's a
smart guy what's he know I thought there
has to be a catch but after talking to
them and using their service it all made
sense there isn't one I was doing I was
in Canada at my mint mobile mint mobile
secret sauce that the first company to
sell wireless service online only cuts
out the middleman the cut out the cost
of retail stores and pass those sweet
sweet savings directly to you all right
these other services there's always a
catch it's impossible to get out of
there's some fine print you don't want
to deal with any of that let the people
that are giving back to the people help
you out mobile for anyone who hates
their phone bill mint mobile offers
premium Wireless for just 15 bucks a
month mint mobile gives you the best
rate whether you're buying for one or
the entire family and that family start
two lines you toots lines man all plans
come with unlimited talk and text high
speed data delivered on nation's largest
5G Network use your own phone with any
mint Mobile plan and keep your same
phone number along with all your
contacts so it's not a whole hassle
switch to Mint mobile and get premium
while it's starting at 15 bucks a month
to get your new Wireless plan for 15
bucks a month and get the plan shipped
to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com shop that's mint mobile
m-i-n-t-mobile.com
schab cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks
a month at mintmobile.com shop this
episode of the shop show is also brought
to you by the best nootropics on the
plant nootropics it's so hot right now
you're like yeah I don't know which ones
to use what do I do we'll use the one
that you've probably heard about you
heard your friends talk about you heard
your co-workers talking about you're
driving to work like man I wish my brain
was more fired up I wish I could form
better sentences like Joe Rogan I listen
to his podcast all the time wish I could
talk to them wish I could talk like him
well I'm here to let you in a little
secret Joe Rogan swears by uh on its
Alpha Brain the best nootropic on the
planet get you in that flow State helps
you focus on the task get hand it's
caffeine free here's how confident Ana
is in the nootropic Alpha Brain they're
so confident money back guaranteed oh
you don't like it you don't like talking
like Joe Rogan or Elon Musk cool man
send us you get your money back you'll
have to send it back go ahead and keep
the ball do what you want with it give
to your friends who can appreciate it
don't devalue on it how dare you can
keep the bottle and then maybe you come
around and then we don't have to worry
about it but you can save 10 off by
going to audit.com shop schab you
attempt staff not only on it Alpha Brain
but you also get 10 off everything on
that site protein bars Warrior bars
protein powder creatine fish oil
multivitamins workout gear steel Club
maces kettlebells whatever you want
battle root battle ropes we got it all
man on it.com shop 10 off or you can
pick up Alpha Brain at your local
Walmart or you can help your boy out
avoid going to Walmart and help me out
it's a win-win on it.com shop temps off
the entire site especially Alpha Brain
now for reals let's get back to the
program chin
uh you know what wild things are
multiple head butts that's the reason
why he was disqualified and he kept head
button him he's like yeah so yeah it's
round upon
good for him for doing that nice little
takedown
all right so this was oh this is
interesting yeah my boy Nick Davis who's
ultimate better
got wind of this early on and he goes
hey man I'm sure you're covering uh the
the Derek uh Miner fight minor fight
stuff and I go uh what's going on with
it so me and Nick chatted about it so if
you haven't heard yet so uh during your
see uh Vegas 64 this past weekend Dirk
minor
fell to Jesus Christ I know this name is
first round technical knockout and the
hours leap this where it gets
interesting so get your mind right if
you're listening driving to work right
now and the hours lean up to the fight
Sports books watched as a flood of money
came in from betters on Shay Shay and
not just the money line on Shay Shay but
the Chinese import to win in fewer than
two and a half rounds so that means not
only were they been on Shay Shay they're
betting that you can get a finish under
two and a half rounds
so even Shay Shay to win by knockout in
the first round right
um so much action came in on Shay AKA
Wolverine that he moved from uh minus
220 favorite to minus 420 favorite so
just so you guys know the way this works
is whenever the money line moves big
time and better there's a commission out
there that goes hmm we should look into
this because this this isn't like a high
level fight right let me I shouldn't say
I made a mistake I understand let me
back up this isn't a
big name it this isn't a high magnitude
fight this isn't a two famous fighters
so when a random guy named Shay Shay
Wolverine goes from a minus 20 to minus
420 favorite
literally at an hour before the fight
then the legal investigation team of
betting goes something's going on here
this isn't right so uh that alerts these
investigators uh into betting to open an
investigation to see what's going on
here
I'll tell you what I think happened but
I'll tell you about the rumor mill so
keep going chin so
um our goal is always is to notify the
industry of any potential uh abnormal
suspicious activity as soon as possible
so you can take action as quickly as
possible the U.S Integrity president
Matthew Holt says to ESPN in this case
we hope that by sending a couple we hope
by we hope that by sending a couple
hours before the fight sorry we may have
helped prevent some more suspicious bets
from getting through while it looks like
Miner's injury uh leaked from his camp
and I was leading up to the fight
there's added complication that the
Nebraskan coach by James Cruz Krauss who
shot to James Charles fantastic coach
the same James cross who runs a betting
pick service complete with a podcast I
think it's called one percent shout out
to his podcast one percent uh Discord
server for paying members in the past he
said he makes more money from Jim on UFC
they never did fighting and then
remember that little thing that came out
with UFC saying that if you are a
fighter or your team member or whatever
you can't bet on fights so for him a
coach he said he could well he's retired
but he's a coach yeah he's a coach
yeah it's like Dusty Baker been on the
Houston Astros I don't even the biggest
Astros fan I'm just in Houston this
weekend so come see me Thursday Friday
Saturday I'm actually a Phillies fan
yeah I like uh Bryce Harper but they
lost in Houston cheats all the time but
still see you soon Thursday Friday
Saturday Houston uh so this is at man of
the library but James Krause is still
actually been on fights and bragging
about he's also been about involving
Fighters that he coaches that's where he
gets nice yeah he has people for their
accounts to make bets and manipulate
markets with 100 win guarantee how can
one guarantee 100 win in the UFC and
James Scott says none at all I'm not a
UFC fighter anymore and uh this guy
Beast like one one nine shout out to
Beast like one one nine well I know
you're retired but wasn't sure if they
were going to come at the teams too but
then again I don't know how they can
even do that but great news
then James cross but nah we good yeah
you know I said no we good I I urbaned
it up a little there for you guys he
just put nope we're all good
um that's dicey being a coach bet on the
fights um and this guy but I am in his
paid gambling group and I don't feel
like if anything like what you described
as having he gives out his picks usually
later on Friday afternoon and that's it
I don't think there's any pumping or
dumping going on anywho
um yeah that's a lot of things going on
I think uh yes James Krauss is a head
coach of a very successful team and
obviously makes a lot of money giving
picks and betting because he's a great
expert when it comes to UFC and mixed
martial arts so he's probably somebody
should listen to
um I would probably not bet on the guys
that are from his Camp right because
obviously he's gonna be a little biased
there and I would assume too he never
picks against his Fighters can imagine
if he was fighting like what the [ __ ]
dude you said I was gonna lose another
two and a half round the [ __ ] yeah you
know so that gets a little dicey that
gets a little cloudy judgment there
um but I what I think happened is uh
Krauss knew that
um Miner had a pretty bad injury
and this is where where this gray area I
don't think it's that gray I think it's
kind of
poor taste to leak the news that the guy
has a knee injury that's training your
camp and to tell others to bet on his
opponent shayshay The Wolverine
uh I don't think anything illegal
happened here right yeah but that's
still a guest it's a gray year it's very
gray it's gray when I say gray I mean
it's dark right it's dark dark gray dark
gray matter here
um if I'm uh the cruise I would probably
stay away from that one
um
you know yeah what do you think and
listen James Chris is a great guy too
that's the other thing it feels like a
sleaze bag I'm like oh this is some
[ __ ] but he's a really good dude and
he's a great coach knows his picks
making a living more makes more money
off picking bets and betting on Fighters
than he does coaching and fighting the
FC
do you have a problem with it chin I can
see how people do I don't know what
really happened though so I don't know
so let me ask this in so would you have
a problem if Dusty Baker right he's the
old I think he's 74 oldest coach to ever
won a World Series he's he he has like 2
000 something wins before he won a World
Series as a manager he takes over
Houston who's notoriously known for
cheating right got busted whatever still
goddamn good team and I don't think they
achieved this one but it's fun to talk
about it so let's say Dusty Baker the
manager right so Dusty Baker would be
the same things as James Cruz Krauss
right across so Dusty Baker would you
have any issue if Dusty Baker uh he knew
let's say uh uh his star pitcher was
injured and he found out Dusty Baker was
telling people to bet on the
Philadelphia Phillies If he if he knew
and he was actually betting against the
guy because he was injured then I would
say that's pretty shady now I'm gonna
give Jim Strauss uh a bit of a uh you
know lead share on this where I think
he probably told some of his close
friends right uh loose lips sink ships
he probably told a couple close friends
hey mine's needs way worse than we
thought it's so bet on the other guy
by Joseph's close friends
loose lips sink ships and his close
friends started you know telling other
people and you know how much money would
have to go on that money line to
actually change from minus 220 to 4 20.
a ton of people so a ton of people got
in on or some jackass got on line on
whatever site he's on or on his social
media and they really gets traction so I
don't think like James crafts was like
Hey everybody Miner's like super [ __ ]
up bet against the other guy that's my
pick of the week like that would be
ridiculous yeah of course he's not that
stupid he's a good dude great coach too
so I think you told a few close friends
and then this then this happens you know
it's definitely great it's a gray area
I don't know what the UFC is going to do
because if you tell James Krause you
can't bet on the fights for your coach
guys
can it it's a gray area because if I'm
James krasco cool I just want Corner
guys anymore you can't say I can't coach
them or they can just say
I'll still coach them like I always do
they'll put somebody
else down on paper as their head coach
I'm still going to help them game plan
stuff like that and train out my gym and
I'm just doing a bet so I'm James cross
I'm making that much money off betting
I'm not just gonna give that up yeah but
I'm like I'm like prove it yeah I help
them get ready for fights I left their
head coach put that in the contract he
could just help his buddies to bet for
him simple as that they're not going to
be able to track that we can't tell your
buddies the bet well he could say all
right I'm done betting but like but they
can't say you can't even recommend right
I mean just don't tell anyone and just I
mean don't tell any of the authorities
but you tell your buddies hey bid on
this is and then you guys get yeah but
you're not gonna make money doing that
so he has to still keep his show one
percent right so he can say all right uh
you'll see notified I'm actually out I'm
I'm no longer personally embedded on the
fights although I'm sure maybe he has a
profile like whatever you know rank D
you know [ __ ] dreadlock boy or
whatever you want to go by you can feel
better under that weird Anonymous
account but he can't officially bet it's
not like UFC can put an umbrella and go
if you train in the gym with a
professional fighter you can't bet if
you train with anybody and they're in
the UFC and you help them out in any
capacity you can't bet on fights there's
no way you can't do the umbrella how far
is that going to go then nobody in the
gym can bet anymore yeah there's no way
so James grass listen it's gray it's
murky I don't think you do anything bad
here I think he told a few couple Dumb
Friends who blasted out now he's in this
situation and now they're risking his
business but he should be able to be
smart be able to maneuver around this
he's still a good dude great guy listen
to his picks not mine
all right did you know Mark hunt fought
over the weekend I sure did I sent to
Rogan I said dude he's 40. how old is he
48 48 his opponent is 37 undefeated 37
undefeated it's not like he fought some
bomb and dude he liked this dude up
the Highlight is fantastic
[Music]
great body shot that the body shot hurt
him
and remember this is boxing kids and
this guy was lighting them up too
that guy's jacked
they got he looks like if you if you're
only watching and says he's driving to
work he looks like Anthony Joshua but
from New Zealand imagine Anthony and
Joshua but if he grew up surfing and
killing fish
rocks him there the guys rocked boom
boom boom boom
that's Mark hunt Daddy yeah it's super
cool to see
at 48. you know I was supposed to fight
Marcon after he fought Bigfoot silver
remember that I think Bigfoot or someone
not Mark but I think Bigfoot tested
positive but it was it's regarded before
that kind of black guy on that fight
where Bigfoot tests positive it was
regarded as like the best heavyweight
fight all time roots of fight made
shirts greatest heavyweight fight of all
time but then that came out so I had to
pull the shirts I think so if you got
one hang on to it and then after that
fight I was on a win streak I forget how
it was but me and Mark uh hunt started
talking [ __ ] to each other on Twitter
and he DM me if you really want to do
this I said I'm down man I was like I'm
just gonna take this [ __ ] Behemoth
down and try and finish him which is
easier said than done but um going back
and forth the UFC sent me a contract for
somebody else well no I I was texting
Danny no me Mark literally agreed to
fight and to Dana's defensives that's
not really how it works you guys don't
create your own fights and we just put
the contract together I was like
yeah I know but he said he would fight
me goes cool dude we don't give a [ __ ]
we have somebody else in mind feeling
all right that makes sense I'm an idiot
I also do that with for Doom too mean
for Doom we're supposed to fight we
agreed to fight
he's like I'll fight you and I'll fight
you on the moon I was like oh it's a
terrible matchup for me everything was
legit oh my God he's better at
everything he's such a nightmare Let's
help you know that's how [ __ ] uh when
you're a fighter man you got this weird
arrogance about you that was a nightmare
thank god dude if he was like what no
[ __ ] you're fighting somebody else
cool
that would have been cool to see you and
hunt though like honestly I wonder but
me and Hunt were like talking [ __ ] to
each other on uh I was making fun of
like his cardio and how slow it was and
I was just gonna take you down and rip
your [ __ ] neck off you know just
whatever [ __ ] but on DM's like hey
man huge fan here you know it'd be an
honored fight he's like I get it boss I
get it man he's like we gotta sell the
fight he said calm down tell UFC to sign
the contract I'm like you tell me he's
like I don't talk to him and he's always
you know he has the mark hunts fight as
and the UFC needs to be careful because
as you know badass of as Mark Hunt is
and you're talking dude Mark hunt you're
talking about like a real oh like as
tough as they get probably top five
toughest guys to ever enter the ACT a
real I know everyone say get you know
harms like gangster Nate Diaz gangster
shut the [ __ ] up Mark Hunt is a legit
hard-nosed gangster when it comes to
fighting no I'm not talking about
illegally in that the dark arts and the
mafia and trafficking no no Drive
trafficking you know and shaking people
down I'm talking about when you talk
about gangster Mark Hunt is your poster
boy there's nobody tougher than Mark
[ __ ] hunt when Mark hunt has a
mission he's going to get it done Mark
Hunt's mission is to fight the UFC
because remember
he opened up that lawsuit against the
UFC and I think it's still ongoing I
know he's taking some L's because again
this is a money thing so the UFC's this
Powerhouse they're never going to run
out of money so they're going to fight
this till the day they die but Marcon is
putting up the good fight because
remember the UFC had Mark hunt fight
Brock Lesnar knowing Brock Lesnar was on
extra sauce and allowed that fight to
carry on eat no Knowing damn well Mark
I'm sorry Brock Lesnar was on sauce so
that's Mark Hunt's argument right yeah
but I'm the UFC anybody out there you
were too loosey-goosey the term gangster
homs like gangster Nate Diaz gangster
nobody and I know Nate this is those
great quotes and it's it's fun to do and
stuff like that and Conor McGregor and
his ties to that stuff
when I tell you nobody is more if I had
to have somebody in my fox when you
listed all those guys Mark hunt would be
my first choice the only problem is it's
gonna be a tight fit in that Foxhole
with me and him in there it's going to
be two thickies in that Foxhole Mark
Hunt is a massive man Marcon is top five
toughest human beings to ever exist in
Combat Sports
and he just saw what he did against an
undefeated boxer he still has it you
know so his
his chip on his shoulder with UFC the
UFC's messing with a different quote
unquote gangster it's not the guy you
want to upset man he's a real one Legend
straight up [ __ ] Legend from The
Pride days K1 I mean dude scary mother
trucker man
yeah his comeback in UFC was insane it
was awesome remember he was losing uh he
remember he came over you see and it was
rough he came up hold on let me see if
uh if if I've CT or not he came out of
the UFC remember he got uh key locked by
matrion's boy he got key locked early on
I forget the guy's name you know like go
to Mark Hunt's record
foreign
guy too
remember he's friends with Metro and
Josh Barnett
I can't remember his name right now Sean
McCorkle oh that dude okay remember Sean
McCorkle super tall guy a big guy dude
how about this he lost by a straight
armbar to gay guard musas super Hulk
Grand Prix and dream in freaking Japan
dude oh he had a tough stretch so he
lost to Josh Barnett so that but this is
my thing you know I I think at the time
I was like a high level brown belt right
I was feeding myself in Jitsu I was
submitting guys to midrione was open for
Mark hunt
um
remember so they give them Josh Barnett
and pride oh the pride days dude this is
the open weight Grand Prix quarterfinal
Josh Josh Barnett beats him uh via
camura then he gets Fedor for the pride
Heavyweight Championship he gets Fedor
Fedor eight minutes on the first round
remember the first round was 10 minutes
right it was 10 or 15 minutes yeah so uh
this is 2006 Pride crucial countdown
literally I think the Golden Age of
fighting there's nothing better man than
those Pride days with those [ __ ]
foreign superstars All Sauced up so it's
Mark and remember Mark Hunt's never been
never touched the needle hates needles
was clean this entire time one of the
only guys ever cleaned throughout Pride
one of the only guys clean now when I go
over this record there's not one guy on
there that I'm gonna go over over his
dream record that I could say was
actually clean maybe Gengar Musashi
outside that ready for this
love the guy lost Josh Burnett Josh
Brown has been busted several times for
PT's he was submitted by him uh via
camera then Fedor goes oh you have
problems with Kimura now also to Mark
Hunt's defense he only has going into
that Josh but he's finding Josh Barnett
the who's who now
going into that fight he only has seven
mixed martial arts fights his third
fight ever was against a guy maybe
you've heard of him vanderlei Silva
his third fight ever
in mixed martial arts was against
Evandale Silva in Pride he won that
Split Decision over vanderley Silva then
they go cool story dude here's merko
crocop now this isn't the Merkel Crow
cop Brendan knocked out in the third
round in New in New Jersey this is 2005.
tip of the spear Merkel Crow cop and
Mark hunt has ready for this four fights
at the time he beats him via split
decision so I dude
I don't know that I'm so glad we
stumbled upon this I don't know if
there's anybody with four fights and in
the four fights their third fight was
Van delay Silva and their [ __ ] fourth
fight was merko Crow cop
insane dude nutsos right so he beats him
he goes in Pride he wins one two three
four five in a row then you go okay cool
story here's the pride open weight Grand
Prix which those open weights were so
much [ __ ] fun right uh Shogun one one
remember that they're fantastic it's
just that's real fighting at the highest
level those days the shoot boxing days
the the hammer House Gym all that [ __ ] I
love that stuff yeah it's like uh when
bodybuilding had Arnold Schwarzenegger
and all those dudes and that Gold's
doing the thing hanging out with their
shirts off and short shorts and about
fighting money and chicks the real wild
west days so he gets vanillae Silva with
the he only has three fights Mercury
crop croakop is his fourth fight vintage
Van Lee vintage Marco
he wins four in a row I'm sorry five in
a row in Pride then they go cool story
now we're gonna throw you to the big
boys Josh Barnett gets submitted first
round Fedor submitted same thing camera
first round uh then he fights Alistair
Overeem now I'd love to hear which one
of these guys is clean by the way all
right now remember then Lane murk oh
okay Josh Barnett okay Fedor teach
Thoreau I know his body doesn't look
like much but again to the Head it
probably stays on things Fedor in 2006
vintage Fedor loses him via Camara and
then he gets Alistair over him also
Overeem although mainly people know him
as a uh you know Elite Striker the boy
can grapple his ass off he wins key lock
so he gets
commode and they get the key lock
clearly has an issue with Jiu Jitsu and
then they give him Melvin manuf
Dynamite pride in 2008. and he gets uh
he gets knocked out in 18 seconds that's
how much of a badass smell the manhoof
was and then the pride guys go oh man
that's a shame uh you lost Josh Barnett
fate or Alistair and Melvin then uh I'm
sure Mark was like can I get a drug test
and go shut your mouth and then here's
and now his record gets a little salty
because he's five and five after the
Melvin knockout and then they fight
Gengar Musashi and gagar goes uh you
struggle Jitsu check out this straight
arm bar and Gengar Musashi armbars Mark
hunt who has two fire hydrants for arms
not long very strong he gets submitted
in dream nine in the first round all
these finishes by submissions are in the
first round right off the bat besides
The Knockout over Melvin then the UFC
acquires The Pride right
they get uh Marcon who they weren't
crazy about but they had to take them on
because it's not a contract they give
him Sean McCorkle Sean McCorkle in the
first round again straight armbar
I always thought it was a key like I
don't know why I'm thinking armbar
I don't know that's strange
but then uh march on the verge of
getting cut the him Chris tusha shirt
now this is where me and
um Mark hunt have similar opponents
because I also fought Chris Dutcher uh
around that time I think quite a bit
after this
so his records five and seven going to
the Chris duster fight the UC is going
to cut him
they give him Chris Tasha sure if you
don't Chris toucher he wrestled at North
Dakota I think he was the best friends
the main training partners with Brock
Lesnar real Savage First Team all ugly
this dude's Grill he looked like a bad
guy from every James Bond movie you've
ever seen his just when God was giving
out looks he was dead last in line his
teeth are a [ __ ] tragedy his teeth
looked like a Japanese Japan City
skyline it is a mess when God was doing
his teeth he went he took a break well
how would you say let me get back to
this and then just skipped a few teeth
look at him he does look like a villain
don't you look like a bad guy the nicest
guy though yeah the nice guy and his
record was nutsos going to the UFC
nutsos
hmm I think his record was like 20 and
two something stupid I did not want to
fight that guy but I didn't find him
um so they give Mark hunt Chris tuscher
Mark hunt knocked him [ __ ] silly in
his home in Australia right that's in
his backyard
then I give him Ben Rothwell now what
happens about this I did not know where
to do this Mark hunt Deep dive but I'm
here for it
he fights Ben Rothwell his record's six
and seven he fights Ben Rothwell UFC 135
at the Pepsi Center in Denver Colorado
it might have been at Broomfield Event
Center I had most of my uh fights before
I got in the UFC so Broomfield they do
the UFC's there
so they put Ben Rothwell veteran versus
Mark hunt veteran the UFC refuses to do
heavyweight fights at a high altitude
especially in Denver Colorado they said
we will never do a heavyweight fight
again in Denver Colorado due to the
altitude because of Ben Rothwell and
Mark hunt they just you know it was like
we thought it was gonna be gangbusters
is one of the worst fights you've ever
seen so he somehow edged out a victory
over Ben Rothwell so he's won two now
you can't hold the the High Altitude
Denver fight against them even though I
had no issues with it we're not a big
deal he's these guys better me so then
they give him check Congo two Strikers
this is in Japan Big Boy fight he knocks
out check Congo and then what I think is
the most disrespectful knockout of all
time Stefan struve because he's seven
foot when he gets knocked out it just
looks bad like if you're a hunter you
see a hunter shoot a dare it's whatever
you see a hunter even shoot an elephant
because they have low leverage to the
ground it's whatever when you see a
hunter shoot a giraffe there's something
so disrespectful because the giraffe's
neck and everything it all comes down
like Twin Towers it's just a nightmare
so he knocks out Stroop nightmare the
him Jews of Santos shot Junior dos
Santos spinning uh hook kick was
ridiculous by the night right and then
he gets Bigfoot Silva Antonio Silva in
2013 it was fight of the night in
Australia it goes to a draw it turned
out to be a draw a lot of people think
that it is the greatest heavyweight
fight of all time but then slowly as a
fight you know age like fine wine you
find out Silva result was changed to no
contest due to a failed post-drug fight
uh drug test so while hunts remained a
majority draw
so really this should go to hunt then
they give him Roy Nelson who has the
greatest chin of all time
I know from experience he's tough to put
away Roy Nelson uh gets knocked out with
an uppercut and it's knocked out of the
year when it's knocked out of the year
in 2014. that's vintage Roy Nelson man
and after that gets all dice form he
gets Febreze over doom and that was in
Mexico City remember
um and Mexico City again high altitude I
don't know why they keep putting my boy
Mark hunt in high altitude Metro City's
so [ __ ] high he's for Doom there
that's a fantastic fight then they give
him Stipe he loses to steepe that's when
steepe starts off on his [ __ ] tangent
and uh becomes world champion then they
give him Antonio
Bigfoot Silva again and Bigfoot Silva uh
gets knocked out this time so that ends
that and then he fights her boyfriend
mare which is uh not nice and he knocks
mare out so he's on you know his Legend
is building then they give him Brock
Lesnar you'll see 200 when the biggest
ufcs of all time his original unanimous
decision win for Brock Lesnar remember
he just wrestled him in that fight
refused in with him he was terrified
you've never seen a dude as big as Brock
Lesnar more terrified to engage in a
fight than his fight against Mark hunt
boring fight UFC 200 huge disappointment
he had uh he had Anderson DC on a fight
remember that because Jones was supposed
to be on it but but uh fell out you know
that yeah she had uh Amanda Nunes you
had uh Miesha Tate Lesnar hunt Cormier
Silva Aldo Frankie Edgar II
ridiculous card remember they had that
weird orange mouth that looked like [ __ ]
uh so poor um
poor Mark hunt that's why he has his
lawsuit with the FC they knew that Brock
Lesnar was just Juiced to the gills and
allowed him to fight uh the legend
Marcon and he hates that and then the
UFC goes okay cool here's uh Astro
Astrid knocks out with a vicious [ __ ]
knee then remember they give him Derek
Lewis which we thought was gonna be a
great fight he knocks him out in the
fourth round that's in New Zealand
here's the thing you don't want to fight
Mark hunt
in anywhere near Australia New Zealand
Australia you gotta find that Heil too
for God's sakes
then after that gets dicey the game
Curtis blades awful match up for him
Alex Olynyk awful matchup for him and
then Justin Willis was his last one
deep dive on the gangster Mark hunt
that was cool shout out to Mark hunt
that was fun I really wanted to pay him
to leave he's like no he's gonna fight
out his contract and then he started
killing it a few guys yeah same thing
when the the UFC acquired Strike Force
they got a lot of their Fighters because
their contracts they had to obey to even
though they took over the identity that
was you know Strikeforce when they took
over Pride because you know Monopoly
right it's a monopoly and so they would
just acquire Pride which I think was a
huge mistake that she left Pride where
it's at and just build it professionally
like they did in the UFC and they'd have
a massive draw over there because
remember I mean
in
in Australia the you know uh Whitaker
alasana is the biggest gate of all time
so they still have some of those big
shows showcases like that but dude when
you're talking about the Tokyo Superdome
from Japan
and they're trying in China now it's so
short side where if they would have left
pride and because the the Asian market
knew Pride they loved Pride the American
Market love Pride the hardcore is still
swear but you say pride is dead you
might get shot dude that's why I get so
much hate I fought Pride guys I fought
no Guerra if I Crow cop I knocked out
crook cop then no gear got me your boys
want them one all right one and one
against pride pride is dead Pride died
when the UFC [ __ ] took it over not
because of me I died when the sea took
them and then did their thing but
yeah Mark hunt the point of this entire
rant is that more you guys are too loose
with the term gangster marcon's a real
Gangster and you guys should [ __ ] bow
to his feet he fought everybody
everybody and he helps guys out too now
um
um already so this is a random deep dive
for Marcon huh you guys aren't ready for
that I remember the pride days when you
watched those I think it was VHS at that
time but when you see the shows they
look like amazing Productions the close
thing we have to is one Championship now
the person that uh does the production
for pride is the head producer for one
Championship that's why I see a lot of
common themes there
as far as like production goes and like
experience Pride was the best of all
time
UFC's still not there I mean when Izzy
walks out or there's something it's
still great or when Connor did it was
right there but as far as doing it for
every fight night after night one
championship's close thing we'd have to
Pride
I went to Pride when uh Fedor fought uh
Mark Coleman yeah actual I was front row
you can see me on some of the uh
highlights on the [ __ ] because my buddy
Joe klopfenstein just he was Nunu oh you
rich rich and he had that new money
because he's drafting the uh he was the
first pick in the second round for the
Rams me and him were obsessed with pride
and so he bought uh front row tickets
that they were 600 bucks at that time
was all the money in the world I
remember me and him bought suits inside
the front room we looked like two
[ __ ] everybody else was like Tap Out
Affliction shirts and wearing two suits
in the front row then we're right uh
we're ringside because remember they
found a ring and pride and we're right
where they'd walk walk out and we'd try
to we I forgot what merch I bought I
think I bought a fade or shirt but it
would go like this you think Travis
Scott's much harder to get Pride back in
the day vintage Pride when they first
came it's the first fight ever in
America first and last fight in America
that merch bro
you would have thought it was that Diana
uh Princess Diana uh Pink Beanie Baby
that [ __ ] the lines to get it people
were fighting each other I think I
bought like a medium shirt just get my
hands on it yeah
those were the days the UFC wasn't so
short-sighted man leave Pride leave the
brand of Pride out there then you super
fight Pride versus UFC
you should have the Asia Market what do
I know though
okay so are you gonna Pride you have
Adam Silva remember I was in Silva Pride
guy yeah and then uh and wanted to
retire and big nog talked them out of it
real children
yeah he he did that fly arm bar on
silver dollars yeah
um all right so Jake Paul was on Logan
Paul's podcast impulsive and he was
talking about how he feels the numbers
weren't as good as they should have been
because he has a theory about this he
made some great points you know you can
see what you know about Jake Paul when
he comes to selling fights and ticket
sales and then also fighter pays not
much you can hate on about but this
makes all the sense and I agree with him
in so many uh reasons here he makes some
great points so he goes the pre-buys
were going crazy
um up up and up and on Wednesday when
the news came out about Anderson saying
that he got knocked out or whatever so
remember he's referring to Anson in the
pre-flight uh some interview uh no it
was a it was the pre-fight um press
conference press conference so in the
press conference are you ready for this
fight and still goes I'm so ready for it
and I think it's a language barrier
thing he goes I'm so ready for it I've
been trained so hard I have the best
training Partners to get ready for this
fight I've been knocked out what he said
three times in training camp promise we
do that the commission says
come again and they start looking into
things it was like when cames like I'm
having head issues remember that I think
Kane and Marquette were like we're I'm
having some memory issues do you see
it's too much of a liability I don't
care who you are so
um he continues on up up and up and
Wednesday when news came out elshon
saying they got knocked out whatever in
the press conference the fight was in
Jeopardy and all the this press came out
it was all over like I remember people
texting me because remember we're doing
a fight campaign uh for Jake Paul in uh
Calabasas remember that
um so we have yeah we had Frank Mir and
Jesse on fire coming with Sam tripley
all three of them text me so I found out
to go hey man I don't think the fight's
going down I guarantee it goes down you
know Anderson said he got knocked out
and trained him like no it's a language
thing he he's just trying to
he's trying to
convey to the audience that I took this
so serious I just didn't you know this
isn't a Payday I'm here to win I'm
trading so hard I'm going so hard in the
paint I'm fighting against good guys
they knocked me out he messed up he
didn't think it was a big deal that news
goes everywhere right before the fight
so that was Thursday Friday right before
the fight when most of your pay-per-view
buys happen right they don't happen days
prior they happen literally Thursday
Friday and then day of are the biggest
so for this come out Thursday Friday
completely [ __ ] Jake so
um just knocked over and the fight was
in Jeopardy and all this press came out
the pre-buys tanked all the way down the
general public sees that and is like oh
it's not happening and these are just
great points Tommy Fury pulled out that
nothing to do with Jake that's Tommy
Fury thing
uh Rockman Jr pulled out you know that
that's a Rockman thing that's not a jake
thing but Jake's the biggest name so it
becomes the narrative on Jake that the
fights aren't falling through
um so then he goes oh and Jake [ __ ]
Paul can't get an event together this is
done at kill ticket sales boom boom boom
we're still selling tickets that day
everything went to zero I think we'll
probably go around 200 to 300K which is
kind of upsetting
now 200 300K isn't the end of the world
especially for him but to the level that
he's at yeah that's not great and did it
have the other stuff he talks about also
here it is this is now as a comic too
there's a time there's a there's a sweet
spot to sell tickets so right now it's
like the on season for Comics The
Summer's the off season
um but you're competing with a lot of
stuff so if you're going to play Vegas
or you're going to play somewhere
you want to check what's going on in
that City that's going to compete with
your tickets especially for me if it's
if there's a big UFC in town I'll make
sure we look you know you see thank God
announced their dates previous you know
till they're coming to town so people
can buy tickets and they can Market it
but let's say the UFC was in where am I
assume let's say UFC was in Houston this
weekend and they're doing a big paper
like a major paper if the fight night
bring it on but if it's a pay-per-view
I'm canceling my dick I'm not competing
with it we have a similar fan base right
18 to 44 males they're also in the UFC
right with my background so it's going
to affect my ticket sales there's
certain things that you have to be privy
to my team has to be privy to before we
book venues there's more that goes into
it than me just going book Houston this
weekend you have to look through
everything because you're competing with
so much now and it's inflation there's a
lot that goes into it so he makes a
great Point here and this is how you
know Jake Paul's becoming a master of
promotion when he says this stuff that's
what I like he put Halloween World
Series Sunday football this is the worst
time of year to fight uh but guess what
I had to fight all my fights from now on
will be in the summer there's no Sports
so he's not competing with anything he's
not trying sharing the spotlight with
Tom Brady the World Series who knows
what God else they have going on the UFC
obviously had a fight uh two but it's a
little different but
um it was his worst time here to fight
but guess what I had to fight all my
fights from now and will be in the
summer there's no Sports there's like
this perfect Gap in July early August
which is the worst time for Comics
because every kids aren't in school
parents have to get babysitters
um for Comics too people are traveling
so they might not be in town there's a
lot that goes into it worst time to do
stand up unless you're an outlier like a
Tim Dylan Kevin Hart
um
you know Joe Rogan unless you're a major
outlier than another stuff matters but
if ticket sales matter to you and you're
on the friends of selling out or half
capacity you really got to pay attention
to this stuff it to me it's interesting
and there's nobody that knows ticket
sales better than Bert Chrysler for
whatever reason he has this black belt
and selling tickets prices
venues I talked to burp before I do
anything usually he's The Mastermind of
it
um so he goes I had to fight with you
those two fights fell out right
um and by the way all my other fights
were during covert when no one had
anything to do anything to watch I had
to fight this year I just had to get it
[ __ ] done I'm seeing tired of waiting
around kudos to him not only do you have
to fight but he had to fight [ __ ]
Anderson Silva his toughest fight which
should have been the most pay-per-view
draws and this to me
is so funny because
the criticism on Jake Paul is fight real
Fighters fight real boxers
but then you same people that criticize
him bought his fight when he didn't
fight to your standards quote unquote
real matchups he had a big pay-per-view
share a bigger uh pay-per-view buys when
he fought these guys that you didn't
consider were real Fighters and then he
fights a real fighter answering Silva
and you don't buy it
so what message are you sending to Jake
Paul
if I'm Jake Paul and I'm about money and
I'm not about getting legitimacy in
fighting I'm gonna go okay so I thought
the toughest guy in my career by far
goes decision I got the knock down best
by far my best performance tough side of
my career I made the least amount of
money what message that you guys keep
hounding him about he's not finding real
people he's not doing this but the new
people are buying the pay-per-view more
when he's finding less competition but
they might have a bigger name or more
Instagram followers than Anderson
[ __ ] Silva so if I'm his manager for
my next step obviously the ideas fights
the fight that's the move no matter what
anybody tells them but that's the fight
but also in the future it's like hey
dude yeah you financially fighting real
guys and we know people say well if I
fight you we want to see you fight a
real boxer
but the data shows when you fight real
guys if it's not if they don't have the
same pole as far as pay-per-view buys
where it's not a Woodly who's been the
UFC currently forever or it's not a
pedestrian or it's not a you know uh
kind of a circus act people aren't
buying it and you're risking your
reputation and losses and you know
you're fronting this whole thing you
know and he's also lost his ass too
because he says
again these all great points and if
you're Jake Paul fan this is so you
should be excited about he talks about
how he's from you know this this MVP
promotions is his thing so when these
fights fall out remember he has to put
so much money in the marketing into
renting the venues the Staffing his team
the other teams dealing with other the
entire roster as far as the fight card
goes their camps flights hotels security
the all the the concessions the merch
all that stuff his company has when
heavy lies a crown you want to own a
promotion you have to run all that [ __ ]
now he's probably not putting all that
together but he's still part of it he's
still fronting it money-wise so when
that Tommy Fury fight pulls out he's
[ __ ] money-wise when the Rockman fight
pulls out he's [ __ ] money-wise
then asked until we get going and look
at the drawings and decides because his
language bear talks wants to impress
people and say how tough of a camp he's
had getting ready for Jake Paul which
shows you he respects Jake Paul but he
really [ __ ] up and hurt the
pay-per-view numbers
so it's tough you guys want to criticize
Jake Paul and you're not find real guys
and blah blah blah and then when he
fights his toughest fight you didn't buy
it
and then when he fights the toughest
fight and puts on his best performance
scope that was fake yeah so if I'm Jake
Paul I'm like I can't win just line up
the easiest most famous guy line up the
easiest most famous guy whether it's a
real boxer a former UFC legend or if
it's some [ __ ] kid off YouTube with
30 000 subscribe 30 million subscribers
it doesn't matter
so the message and the the the the knock
on Jake you guys are only adding to it
if you want to see him fight real people
buy the pay-per-view when he fights real
people
don't sit back no that that's not that's
not real blah blah blah because it was
the toughest fight
but now what you're doing is you're
gonna have Jayco I don't know why I do
it then why am I why am I fighting these
guys give me a tough night in the office
why don't you beat up YouTubers and you
make more money
you tell me that Jake Paul wouldn't make
several times more money against a guy
like KSI and they would answer and Silva
according to this research so if I'm
Jake you know y'all don't be taken
seriously I want that validation do you
though
because the proof's in the pudding you
fought by far your toughest test
they really people I mean 300 000 Buys
in this inflation in this current
climate
you know not terrible
it's tough right
yeah what else you got do you think that
Tommy verified will do better than
Anderson Silva yes wow isn't that crazy
I know and I love Tommy Curry I saw one
of his headlines goes uh what'd he say
he said Jake Paul and
KSI need to fight me if they won't be
taken serious in boxing
Tommy Fury I got news for you bubba Jake
Paul is more of a legit boxer than had
toughest fights
he's fighting against [ __ ] the
basketball guy the short guy won the
dunk contest the test fighting you've
ever fought look up your record dude it
does nothing for Jake to fight you I
mean there's some background there I
guess we've had some previous press
you're a reality star dude you just
happen to be the little brother you
share the same dad different moms you
just happen to be the brother of the
greatest heavyweight of all time that's
the only reason we're entertain this
fight
Jake doesn't need to fight you to get
validation if anything that's going to
hurt him you're telling me Tommy Fury's
a tougher fight than Ashton Silva
[ __ ] you dude he knocks Tommy Fury out
in four rounds easy highlight fight you
guys aren't gonna buy that [ __ ]
in case I might have his hands full
I don't [ __ ] know
I only have so much bandwidth I can't
focus on all these YouTubers boxing
trying to get into their to dip their
toe in this fight world the reason I
covered Jake he's a buddy and he takes
it goddamn serious he actually has
talent these other guys they're just
doing it because the cool thing to do
Jake would do it no matter what
that's why I respect Jake yeah these
other guys are just doing the cash in
what else you got all right here's some
news on Paula Costa
um he posted about his him not being
happy with this he's a wild boy man I
respect Costa more and more from his his
he's a great follow too he'll talk some
[ __ ] he's trolled your boy he's a he's a
fun follow though he's a fun fellow so
he put my miserable my miserable
contract with UFC was up in a few short
all right uh my miserable contract with
UFC is up in a few short months he put
what's up if it was up it would be
expired right
um my miserable contract with UFC was up
in a few short months will expire in
time a new hashtag boxers coming to town
boy I'd love to see him and Jake Paul
fight that'd be a fun one
that would be fun
so yeah he'd mentioned the boxing thing
and he's also saying that usada they're
doing it again where they're testing him
at five in the morning what yeah so he
has like proof of it too I think the UC
is using usada as a doorway to annoy
these those who don't want to renew
their Miss Brook contract that's his
theory that
I can't believe you saw this here at 5am
again it's unbelievable this is
unbelievable they come every single day
at 5am [ __ ] you Sada
I'm with him man it's like again
usada is an employee employee of the UFC
they're not a outsourced uh they work in
the UFC offices the UFC hired them their
their UFC pays their salaries
and I thought Danny instead of getting
rid of the 5am [ __ ] he's like this is
ridiculous done fight week now maybe
it's just during fight week which I
agree with 5am fight week or any time
before 8 A.M on fight week is atrocious
these guys need their sleep sleeps more
important than anything they can do it's
so goddamn important so to disrupt that
is just unprofessional you have to take
care of your clients
with this though if it's you know if
it's 5 a.m it's a Once off 5 a.m you're
trying to bust a guy all right I get it
but if it's happening all the time
there's something to podcasts this thing
because you know you'll see a ton of
other guys getting busted at 5am
very shady
but that's part of the problem man it's
like you know
I've had Woodley on the show many times
a food truck he goes yeah talking all
that [ __ ] do you see was a mistake man
you don't realize like they can make
your life [ __ ] miserable and for
Costa you know come off the winner
against Luke rockhold which is one of
the sloppiest fights of all time but you
know he's coming off a win but still not
like I guess what six in the world this
can make your life very very difficult
very difficult meaning this
if you don't play by their rules you're
literally going to get the worst matchup
possible so that what to do they go
podcast is being difficult all right and
then maybe you started goes here's our
list for testing as this week we have uh
cost at 5am UFC's not like no don't do
that to him you're like yeah [ __ ] do
it and then also matchup wise God who
could beat this guy so he can ruin his
value when he leaves here and tries to
box Jake Paul that's all they're gonna
do so you just hold your cards tight to
your chest I learned that I remember
when I was very first going through my
issues with Dana and you have seen
Reebok deal Rashad called me he's like
now's not the time dude save it save it
they're gonna make your life [ __ ]
miserable you're literally working for a
company you know and if the boss has
power of you which they do because
there's a reason why Dana's the boss a
very smart guy did some strategic moves
be get in that position he can make your
life a living hell and making your life
to live in hell it's not like you worked
at thick boy where let's say Casey was
the problem I can't really make Casey's
life too difficult I give you some [ __ ]
projects I guess you know where you're
like all right dude but it's not awful
there's not much I can do in Combat
Sports
dude Danny can make your life very
difficult oh here's the worst matchup
possible
Difficult by worst matchup possible
we're gonna put you on the prelims look
at Roger Huerta learn from Roger Huerta
now these young Fighters they've
probably never heard of Roger Huerta
Roger Huerta was a Mexican American kid
who looked like a [ __ ] Calvin Klein
model and could fight his ass off and
burst on the scene he was the first
fighter ever featured on Sports
Illustrated there's a picture of him I
think it's against Kenny uh flooring him
[ __ ] kicking him in the face Against
the Cage
and he rose to power and got pretty
famous and then started talking [ __ ] do
you know what happened to Roger Huerta
if you haven't heard of him he's
fighting over in Asia now getting kicked
in the face for I don't know Rising on
one Championship there he is that's I
think I'm I don't know
too brutal of the future look at that
America's fastest growing most
controversial sport that's back in the
day dude I remember those days and Roger
Huerta had all this momentum against the
men he spoke well he looked apart he was
in movies he was dating that redhead
from That 70s Show remember that yeah
behind piece I mean you're talking he's
living the [ __ ] life man and then he
got very difficult started to pay money
started demand the stuff the UFC went
cool story buddy check this out
you're not made of any more matter of
fact you're having you're not in the
main card anymore we're gonna put you on
the prelims against Gray Maynard
and then you lose out your cut and it
was like mission impossible for them
Fighters need to learn man and like I
told you Woodley said was one of my
biggest regrets I shouldn't have done it
at the time because they made my life
very difficult there's just no upside to
it wait till you're in you know if
you're one foot out one foot in you have
one fight left let them Market you on
that fight win that fight and if you
know you're leaving then start talking
that [ __ ] but what Paulo Casa is doing
it's just not good
they're gonna get you man nobody's ever
won nobody's ever one they'll suppress
all your [ __ ] all your [ __ ]
everything we'll get Dan Hardy being
difficult was part of the UFC used by
that BTS uh broadcast which to me is the
best in the world they're the you know
they're the Marquee lineup for breaking
down fights I love all those guys Biz
beings on there they're all fantastic
and the reason Bisbee uh filled in now
is because Dan Hardy's not there anymore
UFC can make your life very difficult oh
get him out of there
he has his reptile you know reptilian
mine uh show or whatever he's probably
the reptile full reptiles the smartest
mind we have in the game it's such a
shame they don't use him
and then with Dana has a press
conference and there's a lot of sheep
out there with what Dana says has huge
influence right so Dana goes yeah he was
being aggressive with a girl
well most people aren't listening to me
most people aren't listening to Dan
Hardy the majority of fans go dang you
believe Dan Hardy got fired because he
was sexually assaulting that girl or
whatever the [ __ ] crazy narrative that
UFC comes up with because all they're
going to do is try and devalue devalue
so what you say doesn't have the same
weight to it
meet with Danny that kid's an idiot ah
[ __ ] that guy okay
you know all right
so for these fires currently in the UC
doing that don't man don't there's back
off there's no upside dude they're gonna
ruin your life
be smart about be strategic about know
exactly what you have and then if you do
have a platform like a podcast or even
your social media wait till you win your
next fight and they give you a big fight
and they give you a little marketing for
it to give you your bonus because
there's another thing it's going to
affect you financially too because
yeah I can get your bonus then give it
to somebody else
you know you're not going to get those
sponsorships they're giving to everybody
else you're not gonna get marketed
you're knocking me on the main card
there's no upside to it get your star as
big as possible and if you're on that
side of the fence like man [ __ ] the UFC
as soon as I'm out of here then I'm then
release the hounds
you know that's the move
alrighty and also for for Costa Lassie
on this for Costa let's say you want the
fight with Jake Paul right they're
giving you a terrible matchup
but if you want that fight with Jake
Paul
the UFC is going to give you the worst
matchup possible to Via Nate Diaz until
they pulled that whole UFC 279
conspiracy theory right
so they're trying to to Nate Diaz it
just didn't work out for him but what
they're going to do is give you the
worst matchup possible and let's say you
get knocked down that fight we're now
Paul Casa that [ __ ] you monetarily
money-wise when you go to ask for that
fight against Jake Paul just think of
that your stars kind of diminished he
got knocked in last fight people aren't
really paying attention but there's a
lot of factors that go into that yeah
people weren't paying attention because
UFC didn't give you a spotlight they
didn't even put your fight on the
website people didn't know you're
fighting like they make it really
difficult man
okay but also what do you expect
would you guys do it any other way if
you're Dana these guys are talking [ __ ]
to you you have to show your power again
yeah you're like okay cool dude
ESPN AKA Mickey Mouse my boss here's
what's going on Paulo Casa cool say less
your tweets aren't getting retweeted
your countdown shit's not you're no
longer on the countdowns your merch is
for whatever reason not selling well
weird
you know what I'm saying they can make
it very difficult there's no upside no
fighter in the history of fighting has
ever won that battle say Connor did
Connor talked some [ __ ] to Dana but
remember that's Connor on a yacht and
Gucci pajamas with 400 million dollars
in the bank because he played I'm sure
he has some issues with the OC you never
heard about it until after he was on
that yacht on a boat many many miles
away
I can't really [ __ ] with him maybe he he
put out Dana's DMS to him around that
yeah a long time yeah that's a he he's a
an outlet yeah for the rest of you it
ain't gonna work man
what else you got all right this is kind
of related to Paula costume but it's
more funny than anything so do you
remember way back that Colby Covington
said that he was hooking up with
Pollyanna Pollyanna Vienna no she's like
that
they're actually I think they did
teammates and stuff as well but their
teammate that was his girlfriend for a
while I think so he was saying that they
were hooking up she said that they
weren't
that's a picture of them together too do
me a favor go back
go back to the time yeah polyamir makes
x-ray Claim about Colby let me see that
that's one day ago so that's all this
this is where it's going to so she
before she denied that they had
something together but then now she just
like a question and answer thing with
someone in the ma media kind of a fun
game thing and then she
admitted so those are this is the guy's
name is Alex B Hunan Who does these
question games whatever humanizing
athletes let's ask about your sex past
that's nice so these are all the
favorite stuff right favorite food pasta
favorite drink Coke regular Coke or
we're talking about Coke Zero favorite
color black dark Fair two show never
heard of it favorite video game never
heard of it favorite band never heard of
it fair plays travel France never been
favorite fighterman Nunez makes sense
Fair all-time fight to watch Johanna
versus whale favorite knockout in Silva
Vitor Belfort I like that favorite sport
to watch other than MMA CrossFit
interesting favorite submission practice
arm locks favorite hobby watching anime
okay and then she posted this too
Kobe wanted me to fing him in the ass
but I did not want to he got upset
hilarious she's basically she's kind of
leaning into it though yeah still
doesn't confirm it but that's hilarious
yeah and then
Paula Costa also commented on this as
well uh Kobe wanted me to finish but I
don't want to get upset and I'll go
please don't accuse Kobe being gay as uh
just because Pollyanna said she stuck
her finger in his ass and then
um you're a very childish respect to
sexual taste is let's just post this
little video here
secret juice
[Laughter]
a great father yeah dude out of nowhere
too he's so funny yeah he's hilarious
uh him and Jake Paul will be not so
yeah I wonder how big of a difference
they are body wise all right now
that's a good point Jim well so this is
Sean O'Malley when M.A junkie said with
algeman Sterling planning to sit until
June Henry suhuto proposes an interim
title fight with Sean O'Malley and then
Sean O'Malley wrote this
that he'd rather fight someone who
deserves it like Cheeto yeah right yeah
I'm with I'm with uh listen you know
Cheetos my boy love sugar that makes
sense to me for intern fight and they
have that that word history right where
sugar doesn't say it was a real fight it
wasn't a loss his leg blew out I think
it was due to the leg kicks from Cheeto
so run it back
not only build suga's thing and also out
of all the matchups that's a good one so
who does not good matchup for any of
them yeah so it was a nightmare for all
of them
and one more with uh Sean O'Malley so
remember Sean O'Malley so Bryce Mitchell
before the Peter John fight I might say
good yeah he was like congrats but you
did not win that fight yeah and then
sugar was like this came from a guy who
had sex with his sister or something
like that his dad had sex with his
sister yeah so then so we played that
video already
and then dad [ __ ] his sister to make
you oh interesting yeah
and then Bryce Mitchell heard that
hold on a second
so Bryce Mitchell heard that in this
place caught me inbred I'm going to deal
with that when I see him
he sits on site when he sees him huh
it's outside and then this is what Shawn
O'Malley ended up saying at the end
never called Bryson inbred and it's
pretty much that's it
um
so you just said I never called Bryson
but he just said your dad had sex with
his sister yeah that'd be that video so
he alluded to it of course I'm sure
shawna's respect for him different
weight classes right Brusha said that he
he expected John to win anyways in the
beginning like he picked John over yeah
I didn't have see this a thing with
Comics too like everyone's so sense if
you say anything especially with
Fighters like
Bisping has this problem DC has this
problem but especially Bisping lately
with you know Nate Diaz uh made fun of
him
because he said you know uh Jake it
could be a problem for him you know Jake
poses a lot of threats to him
for what we do guys like Bisping or uh
Chael me not so much Luke because he is
an analyst but for a guy or Dan Hardy
Dan how you really don't pick fights but
Biz being well I will chill well you're
gonna offend certain people but also
like
that's part of the gig man like I can't
just come on and like obviously I didn't
pick Chandler and uh poy I wish they
weren't fighting I love both of them but
other than that I always make picks and
it pisses some people off man yeah it's
just they're so sensitive so
you know for Bryce you know
it's tough
you're gonna piss people off man
uh-huh so there's rumors going around
that Charles Oliveira was gonna fight
Rafael faziv in January I'm with I'm
with Charles Oliver yeah so then he kind
of pretty much denied her I'm with him
there's no upside for trouble over here
tough match up
physio's a monster it needs to be
physive and gaichi straight up
[Music]
but I'm with trials like no I just lost
my belt I'm not fighting this monster at
six it's not happening he should be
fighting Darius physique should be
fighting Justin gaichi end of story
so this is the press conference and this
is
Rael adesanya and Alex pahaira doing a
stare down but it looks pretty trippy
I'll just show you
get to wait on Saturday a potential
fight between yourself and Israel out of
Sanya it seems to be heading in that
direction what's your final message to
Israel at points again of course on
Saturday a potential fight between
yourself and Israel out of Sanya it
seems to be heading in that direction
what's your that guy just looks freaking
scary he's a Brazilian [ __ ]
Terminator man yes you know and I I get
all the hype on him you know and it
always takes me a long to get on a guy's
bandwagon unless you're Sean Brady or
certain guys Michael Chev I was late to
the party Francis I was late to the
party Pierre I'm late to the party I
just you know I know everybody's on his
Brazilian Terminator nuts I just I don't
think you guys realize how good is he is
I really don't it and it's it's honestly
it's disrespectful it really is you're
my brother and he's like I can't wait to
appear again fight Brian I'm sure I'm
fine kid me and Brian have five thousand
dollars bet on it jeez five thousand
dollars because Brian again my brother
Brian they've never seen Pierre fight
besides the Sean Strickland fight oh
dude he's gonna destroy his teammates
what in what world I know he's scariest
nice big thing you see paints him like
he's this Brazilian Terminator it's
disrespectful y'all must have forgot her
but it's a [ __ ] good Izzy is that
fighting you know much more experience
is at this level it's also Madison
Square Garden so it's not like he's
fighting a fight night it's not like
he's fighting in you know in the UFC in
uh Vegas you know at T-Mobile Arena it's
not like you're fighting Phoenix or
Houston or wherever bro they're fighting
at the Mecca the mecca of all fighting
so if already we don't know how he deals
with 25 minutes in Spotlight it just
amplifies that
Daisy it's not drain the office I'm
gonna take that guy
I think the only thing it was just I
mean for me it's just a mental thing you
know having lost two times the same guy
that's the only thing that I would say
yeah otherwise I think there's something
there there's somebody said about that I
think early on you're gonna see Izzy
very strategic very lasered focused and
probably not taking a lot of chances
early on because that's in the back of
his mind but I also think things happen
for a reason and those Knockouts allowed
Izzy to become the you know the best
mixed martial arts on the planet because
he learned all right I do all this
training we come up with a game plan and
then against certain guys like appear if
I don't think the game plan and you know
I try to match these guys you know in a
in a phone booth fight it just gives
them a opportunity to Loop to win so
he's
these learn from that the only time
we've ever seen them have a kind of
Hiccup like that in the UFC was against
Kelvin gaslin
top three middleweight fights of all
time and they tell you he won that fight
but he learned from that you know I
don't think we see that yeah
um this is Alex Perry's sister so she's
a I didn't know she was a kickboxer as
well but now she's going to be fighting
an LFA in MMA but I'll show you uh
whatever fights here
she's Savage like him she's a certainly
look
[Music]
that family is trouble
she's tenacious like your brother
she's the younger sister huh
and she's very very tall too you can see
yeah they're just genetic freaks man
um I'm sure you saw this video no yeah
big princesses
I know he's got to be weighing over 265
there right because he's not freak yeah
so that was pretty crazy
um this was from a one championship
fight I'm not sure which one but he
actually then he got his leg dented by a
kick
it looks swollen
oh that guy just he went [ __ ] this let
me guess what I've had enough he kicks
so oh my God
so that was pretty nasty
Jesus Christ
um this I just thought was just cool
because Conor McGregor had a beard
finally shaved it off I don't like him
clean shaved I know I know he did it for
his Halloween outfit where his mom went
blackface but you saw that too yeah I've
been poor taste huh she said it was not
that but
um oh this is okay people are I guess
they're calling them out on this because
it seems like he's he's losing touch
they're saying like he's a 60 year old
uncle on Facebook or something thinking
something's funny but this is what he
posted
[Music]
it's terrifying I just don't know what
it is he in makeup for a movie what is
this it looks like a shooting Roadhouse
so there's no garage
but this thing's also you know his grill
at the the walk that from a gorilla his
tattoos Jessica didn't match I guess so
whatever it's content I mean and here's
the last one it's just chill sun and
talking about MMA math math always adds
up example counter plus could be equals
only business
five foot man do you see a towel the
right weight commute to him with two
missed weight too interesting music
Boogeyman Arnold Alan gaichi Nico price
equals one brain oh and just kind of
went hard on them yeah interesting
uh-huh
yeah
alrighty I think that's pretty much it
um you've pretty much covered the fights
already too but if you want yep went
over the fight so yeah Saturday night uh
no uh Cowboys fight command because I'll
be on the road in Houston I'm in Houston
this Thursday Friday Saturday Houston
Improv we have a special appearance me
and the thick boy Squad at the specs
downtown uh Houston I'll put on my
profile today so you guys can get the
exact address but
um that's Saturday at the specs downtown
Houston come try the award-winning tiger
thick come get a bottle we'll have merch
there I'll be there the camera Crews
will be there it's my grand old time
that's from 12 to 2 in Houston at Spec's
downtown the exact address will be on my
social media and then Thursday one show
Friday two shows Saturn two shows
Friday's almost sold out so let's get
working on Thursday Saturday Houston
Texas uh make the stallion will be there
twerking for Tiger thick
that's not true and then next week I'm
in Milwaukee just Friday and Saturday
kid has a game on Thursday so we're only
doing Friday Saturday in Milwaukee
Milwaukee improv Jeffrey Dahmer tour you
best believe your boys can be doing
something for that and then Providence
Rhode Island's almost sold out December
1st through the third Providence Rhode
Island can't wait never been looking
forward to it Washington DC DC
improvable my favorite clubs in the
country December 15th to the 17th get
your tickets at thickboy.com we just
released new thick boy diet merch on
thick boy as well you can also get tiger
thick on thickboy.com we got it all
there for you guys get the new stealth
uh camo collection sweatshirts shorts
hoodies we got the hats jerseys we got
it all man but the new uh thick boy diet
just dropped so get you some right now
thick boy diet it has a steak Knife a
donut whiskey that's my diet I have high
cholesterol whatever thinkboy.com get
your tiger thick there as well all right
enjoy UFC 281 this weekend Saturday
night Izzy Alex Pierre it's going down
Coleman event Carlos sparza Zang weilay
and they also have doesn't Porey Michael
Chandler Frank Yeager's last fight Dan
hooker looking to redeem himself Brad
Riddell Renato McConnell that's a great
fight Donald Gray's coming back Molly
the meatball McCann is on there big
Underdog and then my boy Andre petrovski
is about to mop the floor with his guy
that is all going down this mother
Trucking Saturday on UFC pay-per-view
from Madison Square Garden baby so
that's it but Houston I will see this
weekend uh can't wait to see everybody
and then Milwaukee's after that
um thank you guys thanks for watching
hope you enjoyed it love you guys food
truck this week will be with Al Jermaine
Sterling Hall extra boy that drops on
Thursday on thick boy get you some love
you guys be safe till next time I'm out
if you're into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding